la parole est à présent monsieur
françois noël buffet où le groupe union
pour un mouvement populaire
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre l'europe de la défense est
impossible à construire si nous n'avons
pas une défense nationale crédible
mercredi dernier dans cet hémicycle le
groupe ump du sénat s'est associée sans
réserve à l'initiative nécessaire et
réussit d'ailleurs du président carrère
afin de tirer la sonnette d'alarmé et
d'interpeller le président de la
république sur les terribles danger que
représenterait des coupes budgétaires
pour nos armées et pour notre pays à la
veille d'un conseil national de défense
qui assombrit profondément l'avenir de
nos armées et menace notre outil de
défense
comment plaider auprès des états de
l'union européenne pour qu'ils
investissent dans celle ci
si nous mêmes nous utilisons notre
défense comme variable d'ajustement
budgétaire et pourquoi au final réaliser
des économies de quelques millions
certes motivé peut-être par un caractère
immédiat des choses la défense et est et
demeure l'un des derniers leviers de
notre croissance
il faut rappeler que ce secteur nous
apportent des milliards à l'export
il représente près de 400000 emplois
hautement qualifiés et peu
délocalisables
il est porté par un tissu industriel de
très nombreuses pme dont un de vos
collègues du gouvernement nous rabâche
qu'il veut doubler leur nombre
comment parler d'europe de la défense
alors que nous sommes en train
d'hypothéquer peut-être notre
indépendance stratégique
comment parler d'europe de la défense
alors que nous sommes à l'ultime limite
du décrochage capacitaire qui
entraînerait la perte de notre
souveraineté
enfin monsieur le ministre si le
président de la république a pu engager
les troupes françaises au mali et dire
même jusqu'à dire même le 2 février
dernier que le plus beau jour c'était le
plus beau jour de sa vie politique qui
en étant à tombouctou
c'est parce qu'il disposait d'une
capacité de projection et d'un outil de
défense qui le lui permettait ce sont
les moyens budgétaires allouées
aujourd'hui qui gagent rond notre
présence dans le monde de demain
la réalité mais celle mise c'est que
certaines nations sont des moteurs pour
l'europe de défense et c'est le cas de
la france
l'orne l'heure n'est pas à la complainte
mais à l'action et la responsabilité
il vous revient à vous et nous savons
que vous en être convaincu de ne pas
céder aux pressions hypothécaire de
bercy qui annihilerait les 50 ans
d'efforts de construction européenne et
militaire que notre pays a consenti et
doit continuer de faire monsieur le
ministre je souhaiterais savoir au nom
de mon groupe
c'est d'après midi de quels arguments et
de quels moyens
vous allez pouvoir utiliser pour
convaincre le président de la république
de ne pas soumettre le budget de notre
défense un rabot qui serait sans doute
quelque part extrêmement dangereux merci
monsieur jean yves le drian
le sénateur quoi je dispose de ma
conviction et de la vôtre j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de le dire tout à l'heure que
je remerciais le sénat de ses prises de
position concernant le maintien d'un
effort significatif de défense pour
notre sécurité
je ne vais pas vous comprenez bien à ce
moment anticiper sur les conclusions
d'un processus qui est loin d'être
achevée et qui nécessitera des
arbitrages difficiles
je voudrais simplement rappeler j'ai
rappelé que la leur au sénateur paul
combien l'équation était
délicate entre la nécessité d'assurer la
souveraineté de notre pays par la
maîtrise de sa dette parce que c'est
aussi un élément de souveraineté quand
un pays est à la merci de ses créanciers
il n'a plus de souveraineté mais en même
temps il est indispensable de garder une
capacité sécuritaire significative et
donc la souveraineté passe aussi par un
effort de défense significatif c'est le
sujet qui est qui est sur la table à
chaque fois qu'il ya eu un livre blanc
et où une loi de programmation militaire
des questions de ce type sont revenus
elles sont encore plus difficile
maintenant qu' air pur pour des raisons
monsieur le sénateur la première et ne
voyait pas du tout de polémique
c'est que la loi de programmation
antérieure n'a pas été respectée pour
une raison très simple je ne polémique
pas non plus sur ce sujet c'est quelle
avait été établi avant la crise et donc
la projection qui avait été initié dans
la loi de programmation 2009 2014 est
une projection qui n'a tenu que deux ans
quand je suis arrivé de postes de
responsabilité il manquait déjà selon la
cour des comptes mais j'ai constaté que
l avez raison 4 milliards par rapport
aux trajectoires et puis ensuite il y a
les difficultés du moment et la
nécessité d'atteindre les 3% de déficit
budgétaire à la fin de l'année 2014
voilà les contraintes moi je souhaite
être suffisamment persuasifs pour que
nous puissions maintenir un effort de
défense nous permettant d'avoir des
forces armées cohérente et efficace
si vous le souhaitez vous avez trente
secondes de mon champ colibri monsieur
le président en 30 secondes simplement
pour dire à monsieur le ministre comment
ton ce qu'il vient de dire est qu'il
trouvera du côté de ces bancs un soutien
infaillible dans la défense de son
budget afin de donner à nos armes et les
moyens nécessaires permettant simplement
de rappeler que monsieur cameron annoncé
que les ministères chez lui vers une
diminution des budgets de 1% mais que la
défense bénéficiera elle d'un report de
crédit non utilisées gageons que cet
exemple là puissent nous servir dans les
semaines qui viennent merci monsieur
merci la parole art